sit here's Chris Paul from El Segundo
60-footer at the buzzer
off the glass about it keep putting in
buckets at the right time nice [ __ ] Josh
pivot just a jobs a job and Gus gets all
the way to the rim
he's got 32 the Grizzlies watches 22 and
60 that ended one was a seven-year
rottenness of winning seasons and two
playoff appearances at the corner after
some razzle-dazzle or another look at
that oh he goes five hole Chris Paul
with a beautiful pass to Carmelo Anthony
we're gonna be saying that a lot this
season just the ball the ball that's a
lot
Westbrook finds that trailer in the
round with the stop Thunder back up to a
19 point lead
Suns call it top the Tillman is put in
so a lot of great things going on in
Houston Rockets basketball hall with a
strip Oh leaves it back to Carden one
[Applause]
Chris Paul's ready for the start of the
regular season the two points and eight
assists give them another steal what
does that three steals room tonight and
watch this pass between both legs KC
defense returns
[Applause]
jumped off the trampoline how about the
long plane but Terence Ferguson how many
times have we seen Russell Westbrook
doing this play - Terrence Ferguson and
Russ damped a boy he was up there as you
could tell that's all of the emotion so
Chris Paul now is gonna let that ball go
until he can get a running start there
it is he gets it off in time
cp3 with a 3-2 win the first half and as
Chris Paul hits the 17th for offensive
foul well who the street names team up
to Center screen oh I split the defense
and elevates and about this play saw the
space and detonated able to grab those
offensive long rebound
you can play great defense and they're
just times where offensively the
preganant this is good to be pick see
once again by the Thunder just starting
to take control of this ball
[Applause]
in the pocket and Adams knew exactly
what to do with it
final seconds of the second quarter ha
got it right back with two tenths of a
second remaining
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna say that's nasty gross
especially they're closin time passes
awesome
and he just rolls up but you say nothing
but me notices hi Paul lets it fly and
ten in the third quarter with confidence
he let it fly Euston up five heading to
the pool Wilt Chamberlain
well it's easy to under pre she ate
appreciate call charge as Westbrook has
his triple-double
it comes on a play like this here at
this moment in the ballgame Kansas
Kentucky guys all over this way that's
where the one of done guys go home
[Music]
Defensive Player of the Year as well
look at that the Travis turnover trying
to defend and give it up shots to the
bigs
nice pass capela inside lacing up in
Chris Paul home a season-high 14th
assist one of the all-time greats look
at this pass left hand behind the back
step shrewder Leonard missed the follow
Russia with the loose ball
they can get the time Westbrook on the
drive
[Applause]
hi kokes now that is a hard push
Westbrook full speed
splitting the defender and a beautiful
left-hand finish 38 points tonight from
Russell Westbrook today along with 10
rebounds and six assists but no bucket
more important and then this one right
here from Toronto's perspective this is
exactly one of the situations why you
traded for Kawhi Leonard he's got to be
your home run hitter to either create a
shot of his own or for others seconds to
go
Dallas looking for the wind once it got
it up it was blocked Chris Paul with the
block at the buzzer and the Rockets are
five in Wynand Dallas 94 93 Wow Luka
dodge guys all over him and watch Chris
Paul with the defensive play of the game
we got to play defense to win Chris Paul
knows that Brunson has a chance but wow
what a defensive block by Chris Paul
this book wants to push to the Thunder
another
you see Westbrook located one into right
with Stephen Adams who's going to be on
the floor it's over the last couple of
possessions what a fish how about the
Shamgar
believe let's start the beat get it so
fast what's the sambar blue right there
before you did the spin nice most spin a
bit the older the shoulder pass he's
just new Steven Adams gonna be there
that's two guys as they plan together
for a long time I know you're gonna be
there Steven Adams and he put that past
right where Krista Adams was and he
delivered and drank from it or something
he's not sharing it with any of us come
on des where's it at by Chris Paul pic
and got air Gordon going to the corner
and Kenneth three going to the hoop
[Applause]
block by Russell Westbrook on the rookie
one to pick enrolled Harvey Paul Oh
Chris Paul no is maybe it's gotta go you
are the president of Smitty's top plays
on the rim connect oh and the nominees
yes again I mean he crossed over the
entire gym well nobody around
I said nobody nobody helped on it I made
him a little peanut butter and jelly
sandwich book the thunder wanna push
Gallinari finishes with a quick
crossover but he didn't have the shot he
wanted gives it up cp3
[Music]
[Applause]
with the degree of difficulty a little
bit higher than normal behind the
backpack
this is a big possession and there with
their third opportunity to counter than
a foul Westbrook
what a finish is one of these planes
where the rubber meets the road did the
thunder and you got to continue to make
plays like this we had that made it
easier for these guys gonna work hard
with reason Matt and I had two easy
knocks down the three Saudi got sounded
undercut by Jackson not happy they
didn't call it ending sequence for the
first quarter the rookie Jackson junior
he's already undercut up a little bit
got him to a spade thumb to come up with
a massive win on the road but gets a
Phoenix team that was fired as both to
that's a staple all tonight why not but
mister Russell Westbrook Libre with him
sort of sang it off jock fought game
clock Chris Paul with a free sign a
minute to go in the third Nowell reaches
in and gets the steal and here's
Westbrook put the side
seem clear that that is a clear path
fountain Noel with two straight
deflection four seconds on the shot
clock
first Paul
[Music]
Roger
fire no way being under 500 he was going
to be in the next button he's right back
in the conversation Westbrook picks the
pocket up Lillard the NBA leader in
steals Westbrook gets the layup on the
other end to make consistent shots man
he is relentless what he does
expenditure of energy now the three down
to two three pointer that in the corner
Chris Paul to child
gonna toss it up
[Applause]
what
[Applause]
well sure - did you know it was towns at
Tipton and Westbrook picked the perfect
time to knock down his first three of
the night Paul Anka Julia stutter steps
scoops and drops it in one thing he can
do is finger roller we happy you're one
in five in your last six you start this
game
Paul hop on a scale how about that one
came from nowhere and room service at
the other end grew up here and now
you're gonna see when if you turn your
back right there you turn you back and
look the other way he's coming from The
Blind Side years but
no Russell Westbrook with his first
three of the game you force a lot of
tough shots by the trail pleasures
retrieve the loose ball shot clock
winding down Paul pulls back mid-range
to the porn first.this here in the
second half and you chase them off that
line good job
Westbrook nice low capsule around scores
high off the glass
[Applause]
right hot but while all that's going on
how about this year God move russell
westbrook in transition big gonzales
garland chris paul now green dream on
that is picks him up hallway outside new
houses of a dress pop up from downtown
101 they switched the pick-and-roll he
has dream on on him and he makes a
decision i'm going green knocks down the
long well he's certainly gonna get Magic
Johnson in his sights gonna be 11 away
[Applause]
Vanity's matchup with George Bell
defending all its time gets into the
paint pulls back falling away it's good
as the shot clock expires the matchup
you want Chris Paul says allow me to
have this dance knock down beautiful
offense I call that ring in the Bell he
wants to drive outside Ferguson the pass
right back to Westbrook sets the feet
[Applause]
against left this is the three that tied
it 116 and catch fire three I like that
that catch and release
was it a couple of shots in a row ja
clock down to four Paul over beyond both
for three just beats the shot clock
buzzer gonna see these post-ups tonight
for the Thunder because without Paul
George they need somebody else out great
offense just like Ray fountain did their
for Russell Westbrook you know what he
is a savvy veteran that's one of those
plays you can get you can get going off
that folks Clark again down ball leads
it's the Rockets finally make a three
over the top of max of Cleveland he is
so strong with that right shoulder
Thunder with a little bit of time
Westbrook charging down the lane had the
four seconds and used almost all of it
out of five seconds
as Paul splitting and he scores
by the Knicks and decided to side with
Indiana and the injury the whole a Depot
Steven Adams again slicing is dicing
russell westbrook sets him up there was
a kickball so the jasmaine to go fair
there's a fair decision at home takes
advantage and fall dump situation that's
another consistent inconsistent don't
really know what's coming absolutely
convinced to sit back and it gets even
more silly when you hear the whistle let
it go sometimes you will get rewarded
that might be a three it is a three
oh that's clear for me yeah well this
makes us he has more than three they
clearly see Ockham got caught with his
hand
[Applause]
we'll try the job by Steve now and
stretching out what rebound get the good
music got now how he just relentlessly
goes after that contact by Murray slap
it down what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content